ah tiens alors donc ministre l'intérieur
avait cité gérald darmanin ayant poste
marine le pen et christophe castaner
ministre des sports zinédine zidane
yannick noah teddy riner que des potes
maintien s'éloigne estanguet que j'adore
c'est si nerlandaise championne
paralympique de snowboard cross
ministre de la culture les plébisciter
alors stéphane bern bernard pivot aulas
et non
[Applaudissements]
les dents là
oh
m
non
attendez attendez attendez j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'ya pas putsch la
wii non les gars non mais lordon est
générale à [ __ ] mais bof ça est ce que
vous allez faire vous êtes où vous devez
les cabanes en toi moi j'étais pour
sceller musique quelle époque j'aurais
aimé vous entendre sur michel bouquet si
vous regardez niasse pour votre boule
bien je te dois déjà c'est sur celle de
mes amis cités
allez allez vous vous allez faire l'aigu
ration notamment en première période
les hommages michel bouquet est après
moulard y avait à tort j'adore michel
bouquet interflora total tous les jours
mais c'est officiel de la part des
prix de la wii allez-y qu'est-ce qu'on
fait bien moi je ne dirai je suis contre
arrêtés contre sens rappelle ton
empreinte de main ont été pour leurs
enfants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
qu'elle avait
[Applaudissements]
des lots 1
qui viennent
voilà encore une fois un exemple de
démocratie dans cette émission
voilà c'est ça qui est un battant crasse
ils l'ont
pas compliqué écoutez au pad
non mais c'est vrai à mais sérieux vous
voyez moi non mais en tenue au salon du
livre de
la
suite au salon du leader avec les mondes
y avait tous les livreurs des gares et
avec des cagettes
déclaré des camions les fous ce mec là
les jantes et sont la première chose que
je ferai quand je communie de la culture
vous verrez le destitue buy
[Applaudissements]
way concerne assauts lensois il me
permettre je vous verrai plus au sport
ouais ouais unis
les deux corées finances au financement
d'un premier ministre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous acceptez si on vous le
propose bien sûr qu'on prenne la mesure
de la première mesure ces conférences
du coup j'ai hâte de connaître la
seconde
partir à mykonos et à tout l'été au rand
bouraoui
dit non mais oh
attendez dessous federer incroyable moi
je trouvais moi trois animateurs qui
sont capables de faire ça si je prends
mes valises et je me bats
même pas de transpiration n'y a rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à tendance avec un loup l'état
[Rires]
c'est dans le sait dans le slip qu'il
faut
alors les traits des grades dans une
émission elle saura pas ce livre la
téléco
58 au torse
monsieur lucien l'habilité refusant un
héros
de bienséance l'éducation mais pas de
tatouage
[Applaudissements]
le jour où ils égalent tu prends un
ticket un kama la securitate en matière
d'art et mon âge il ya un
mais c'est pas parce que tu y arrives
pas que moi je vais pas y arriver moi je
vais réussir
[Applaudissements]
tous les animaux